[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this of course is a segment where
viewers try to find mistakes on our show
so far many many challengers many people
think they found a mistake no winners no
one's actually found a real mistake I
mean thank God they don't give up
yo exactly I know they keep trying out
and it's getting sad well tonight a fan
named Andy Zagar as the GAR thinks he
caught a mistake
he claims that during my recent
interview with Jack Black I got the name
of last year's American Idol winner
wrong let's take a look hey Conan it's
one of your big fans Andy I caught an
error on your show where you refer to
the American Idol of last year winner as
Scottie McCready
take a look Scott McCready wins it's a
big deal the American Idol winners name
is Scotty McCreery not McCready so I
don't know how you're gonna get your way
out of this one but I think you got it
here
you think he has me this time okay don't
care
well I'm sorry Andy but you are dead
wrong yes it's true that his name used
to be Scotty McCreery but as any real
Scotty fan knows he recently changed it
just Scotty McCready you doubt me just
check out Scotty McCready's latest music
video
[Music]
I was born in Carolina with the name of
the career but I just thought that pain
was too long so I changed it to McCready
which I'm just now realizing is getting
shorter nevertheless
[Music]
you're wrong nevertheless
[Music]
it's unbelievable right unbelievable
that he would do a whole video to put it
to the prior to coincidence yeah anyway
the challenge still stands i kiplyn
believe anybody challenge would
challenge us after that it still stands
if you're a fan you're watching the show
and you think you've spotted an error
reported at team koco.com / haha I found
an error we will sort it out right here
on the end let's see if you have what it
takes to make Chuck meat out of the
maestro